ben spies siamo abitare vitale e oggi
facciamo nel nuovo challenge tre colori
gli origami sono simili alle sole che
abbiamo già fatto tre colori di slide
con la nicola tra i colori di glitter
tre colori diffida ai ragazzi ci saranno
tre colori di origami xché sono il trend
del momento
se non avete visto il nostro scorso
video in cui facevo vedere tutti gli
origami e facciamoci moreali contro i
signori piani facciate vederlo dopo
questo video potete trovare appunto yuri
garics in edicola intenti mi avete
chiesto ma di cose sono forti sono fatte
di carta no non sono fatti stilicone e
profumato quindi si possono ritiri
tantissime volte in più profumano la
stanza sono fantastici quindi noi
andremo a pescare tre colori bendati poi
dovremo fare una creazione con quei tre
colori
dovremo fare la stessa creazione con
quei tre colori fatele voi per ogni
turno dovrete votare qua nel sondaggio
se mi piace di più la mia creazione o
quella di vitale quindi state bene
attenti guardate bene il video fino alla
fine si poi vediamo chi ha vinto in base
a quali creazioni visto non riesce un
trittico che il ragazzo le nostre
challenge emettere ricordi e siamo
giudicare
proprio grazie a quella formerà band
dove vediamo allora andiamo mischiare i
colori ho fatto tutto l'arcobaleno
bellissimo qua a montichiari e perché ci
sono queste bustine da 50 persone da 25
pedrosa che gli uomini quelle bicolore
da 50 e colore speri che ti capiti nero
lombardi voleva così almeno progresso un
colore bello è che sono tutti i graffi
che come lei gira wow
hai giocato un bellissimo
bellissimo ruota quindi getta iniziando
me sembravano pronti fra ore contate sta
succedendo berbera cattivo ai magazzini
[Musica]
all'estero oppure via l'africa o contro
il werder dopo i fatti di verde dove lo
mettiamo il legno che hai detto in villa
e gente assolutamente verso porto non è
che li stai mettendo lontano fatta ed ha
messo dimenticando di vistare queste
allora questo qua che fortunata colore
preferito di vitale neanche quello di
questo misterioso siamo in cammino
proprio così verdi che però va messo
cardo lino e guarderà cosa dev'essere
polemiche per scatti il verde
bello bello
[Musica]
tenendo mettermi messo qualcosa con
vicino in via brenta quindi vuol dire
che il colore che non mi piace annuncio
ma le scelte di questo è uno dei colori
più seri alcuni sono flussi bellissimo
vedere bene resto quando come abbinare
al seno non ci fa bene sia bello e più
chiaro vediamo fare
colori senza colore rilasciato
integrazione effetti che a bocchino
secondo merito il blog di marco vito lo
re disabilità dobbiamo poi dove capita
[Musica]
ok arrabbiata mai vivo ma ero un pochino
più chiaro quindi vediamo cosa per cui
adesso topesco grotta metus il anno
quando i quali fatti
[Musica]
secondo te qual volta vi metto qualche
bellissimo colore perché non vuoi me lo
prendo
vediamo benissimo vedremo qual è il sì
la più bella
ora andiamo a creare qualcosa che vive
tre colori e poi potrete votare il quale
vi piace di più delle due frazioni siamo
frati il rettore
ora abbiamo deciso di realizzare il
braccialetto ferì quindi il braccialetto
fatato ci servono 18 pezzi per ogni
colore siamo pronti iniziamo
[Musica]
a me piace un sacco che si abbina molto
alla mia mal davvero sembra un
braccialetto di una squadra di calcio
sicuro è vero è se quello di vitale
sembra molto più colorato perché lui ha
mischiato tutti i colori sono il primo
colore poi l'altro invece ho fatto delle
strisce di colore vedete qua c'è già un
profumo buell nero nella stanza come più
meglio mi votate votate quale preferita
di braccialetto il mio o quella di
vitale dove sono tutti i due bellissimi
sembrano dei fiori questo sembra proprio
un fiore più bello
votate secondo round vediamo che voglio
celeste ok impatto dai propri di manu
chao ha subito che sarà stabilito che
abbiamo già due colori quindi dovrebbe
stare solo un'altra volta
verona mestolino ed io benvenuto ai
viola
[Musica]
[Applauso]
prendo questo perché sia un grotta o sue
bird stia non è possibile se n'era solo
uno in mezzo a tutti questi però detto
che quindi sarebbe capitato e capiterà
un'altra questo torino già bello che
volete vivere solo uno perché da due
colonne di riposo pescare aver terminato
devono sanare
[Musica]
che impresa dai conforto di riavvio non
mischiate ma non riusciamo in fanno pure
dello stretto stato allora che prendono
una vaschetta così auguro già due colori
prendo questa vediamo rosa e celeste
tu invece il viola verde acqua
allora abbiamo deciso di realizzare la
genziana che un fiore forattini
[Musica]
ha unito il nostro fiore in carini
filoni uno stato all'altro allora nel
mio ho osservato i petali rosa celeste e
rota e poi c'è il gambo verde quindi il
veneto è stato molto utile se invece hai
fatto così beckham borrelli spesa di
celestino centro invece viola quindi
votate con le fiere mi piace di più
quello di evitare o quello della vita
cliccate nel sondaggio e votate che
carini
[Musica]
www interessante questo colore giallo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
pdl
in realtà mi piacerebbe prendere
un'altra partitina perché quelli dove
sono più così posso avere già due colori
quindi speriamo bene
3 sonore per teatro mi piace tanto che a
fine agosto quando dunque tubo legami
che gli vengano belli
beh quella preti e non sorprendere le
scatoline questa è per colore rosa
ok ora dobbiamo fare questo pezzo
crescere ok per la nostra testa
creazione di un tessuto di parma
carreggiate rete la tartarughina dovevi
vedere come si rosa prati via
[Musica]
tartarughine pronto vittima entro io ho
fatto le foto di mare allora sì è vero
da potermi rivolgere filovia un po verde
un po bardolino un po roma la supercar
in a a qualsiasi profumo uno stacco
quindi come soprammobile nella cameretta
è fantastica
quindi votate quale vi piace di più la
mia quella di vitale e votate quali
sondaggi ora vi facciamo vedere che
l'abbiamo realizzata anche con i colori
originali si trasformino finale però che
carine con le difese di brook lopez e
tre queste quella con i colori originali
come da istruzioni e da tutorial che
questa è quella che ho fatto io e questo
è quella marina digitale che mi
piacciono tantissimo sono super ténéré
carine stata ecco quindi i nostri fiori
bellissimi
eccolo merito e qual è pronto ad esservi
e questo è quella digitale
noi abbiamo i nostri bellissimi
bracciali un po più e le nostre torte
vine carinissimo sono troppo temere le
carezze un pochino religiosi ma cosa
importantissima che faremo un altro
video con migliori gamix quindi questa è
la vostra occasione per inviarci le
vostre creazioni qualsiasi cosa avete
creato con gli origami mandate mila su
instagram e sarà la vostra occasione
perché nel prossimo video farò vedere le
vostre creazioni nevi salute oppure se
volete pubblicarle su instagram taggate
mi nome anita stories così le mezzo cioè
le faremo vedere nel prossimo video lo
vedremo se tfr visto lotteremo che li
raccolgono 903 crispino amici purini
commenti che ha tre challenge e volete
che facciamo nel prossimo video con seri
gamix e ora mi lasciava quattro
cartellini su cui di campo e vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite